- Thank you, thank you everybody.
And thank you for joining
us for session four
of 10 questions this evening.
I think you may have
noticed we are no longer
in Kaufman Hall, or Kansas,
anymore this evening.
We are indeed still here and part of UCLA,
and out of respect for
striking UCLA health employees,
patient care, technical
employees, service employees,
and university professional
and technical employees,
we have moved tonight's
session off of the UCLA campus.
This move signals our concern for
and commitment to all who work at UCLA,
and particularly those
that are most vulnerable.
We want to thank all of
you here who have made
the move with us this evening.
Thank you for making it across
Sunset Boulevard safely.
I want to especially
express my gratitude for
Marymount High School's community
for offering us this terrific venue
in this space this evening.
We are fortunate to have
such a wonderful neighbor,
and thank you all in the
Kaufman Hall production team
for supporting us and
helping us with this move.
Everybody join me in thanking Marymount
(audience applauds)
and everybody from Kaufman
Hall that made it over.
Thank you all so much.
Without further ado, let me introduce
the extraordinary faculty who
are joining us this evening
to help explore tonight's question:
What is freedom?
Please if our guests could come on up.
Come up up y'all.
(audience applauds)
In any order you would like here.
We have as always four
terrific faculty members
from across the entire UCLA campus
that will join us for this
evening's conversation
and tonight's question.
I'm gonna briefly introduce
each of four guests,
and then as we've done
before turn to those
our four guests this evening
to make their presentations
to open the conversation.
First, from the School
of Arts and Architecture,
Andrea Fraser,
(audience cheers)
(laughs)
is a Professor and Chair of
the UCLA Department of Art.
Her work is closely associated
with institutional critique,
feminist practice, group
relations, project-based art,
and context art.
Andrea has worked in performance, video,
installation, sound, text,
and a variety of other media.
Seanna Valentine Shiffrin
(audience applauds)
is Professor of Philosophy
and Pete Kameron Professor
of Law and Social Justice
at UCLA where she has taught since 1992.
Her research addresses
issues in moral, political,
and legal philosophy,
as well as matters of legal doctrine
that concern equality, autonomy,
and social conditions
for their realization
Ananya Roy.
(audience applauds)
Ananya is Professor of Urban Planning,
Social Welfare, and Geography,
and the inaugural
Director of the Institute
on Inequality and
Democracy at UCLA Luskin.
Her research has a determined focus
on poverty and inequality,
both in Los Angeles as
well as other cities
around the world.
Lauren McCarthy
(audience applauds)
is an artist and assistant professor
in the UCLA Department
of Design Media Arts
in the School of the
Arts and Architecture,
and is the creator of P5.JS,
an open-source platform for
learning creative expression
through code online.
Her work explores issues of surveillance,
automation, and network culture
as they affect our social relationships.
As I said earlier, as we've
done in the previous sessions,
I'm going to invite
each of the four guests
to stand up and give a brief presentation
after which we will open the conversation
to not just everybody on the stage,
but everybody here in the room.
And with that we have
agreed a running order
that will begin this evening
with Seanna's presentation.
(audience applauds)
- Well I'm here as tonight's philosopher,
but also tonight's lawyer.
Philosophers are interested
in lots of forms of freedom:
freedom in the sense
of freedom of the will,
freedom from unmet
material needs and wants,
freedom from unjust constraint, coercion,
harassment and other kinds of domination
by people and organizations,
and freedom in the sense of
having a range of opportunities
to develop, exercise, and display
one's individual abilities,
character, and moral judgment,
and conditions of mutual
respect among others,
including the opportunities for fulfilling
work and leisure, for equal
political participation,
and for supporting, loving,
and chosen relationships.
These are all vital forms
of freedom and, indeed,
the quest of some UC workers
for these very forms of freedom
is indirectly why we're here
tonight at this location.
But the direct reason we're here tonight
is not their cause, but their protest
through the exercise of freedom of speech,
and that's my topic.
I wanna take my time to
discuss the relationship
between freedom of speech
and freedom of thought,
and how their legal
and cultural protection
underpins the freedom to live a life
of meaning and authenticity.
My claim is that freedom of speech
is critical to freedom of thought,
and in turn both freedom of thought
and freedom of speech are essential
for meaningful thoughts,
meaningful speech,
conscientious and authentic
self-representation,
and ultimately meaningful
relationships with others.
I'm gonna take as my starting
point a landmark legal case
involving the Constitutional
right not to speak:
West Virginia Board of
Education v. Barnette.
In 1943 the Supreme Court recognized
that students have a First Amendment right
to choose not to recite
the Pledge of Allegiance,
and so I ask you all to join me
in exercising your right to decide
whether to recite the
Pledge of Allegiance.
I hope you'll decide right now not to,
but I was asked to think
about audience participation,
and that's the best I could do.
(laughs)
I'm sure the others
will be better at it.
But back to Barnette, the
litigants in that case
were a really brave family
of Jehovah's Witnesses
who objected to reciting the pledge
given their religious commitment
not to worship false idols.
The case happened after a
summer of very intense violence
against the country's Jehovah's Witnesses
for their stance on the flag,
and the Barnette court held
that compelling children to recite
the Pledge of Allegiance
violated the First Amendment's
free speech guarantee.
In its most stirring passage,
Justice Jackson's majority
opinion proclaimed,
"If there's any fixed star
"in our constitutional constellation,
"it's that no official high or petty
"can prescribe what shall
be orthodox in politics,
"nationalism, religion, or
other matters of opinion,
"or force citizens to confess by word
"or act their faith therein."
During that fraught time
full of anxiety and fear
on the brink of World War II,
the Barnette court took an important stand
to respect religious minorities
and to protect nonconformist expression.
This year we celebrate that
case's 75th anniversary.
But the controversy over
Colin Kaepernick and his view
shows that the wisdom of that decision
has not been fully absorbed in the culture
and, hence, it's worth returning to.
You might wonder why
this freedom of speech
demanded the right to remain silent,
after all isn't all that's important
is that one has the freedom
to say what one thinks
and to have one's views understood?
No one takes a compelled
recitation to reflect
the speaker's deepest thoughts.
It's socially understood
that it's a ritual
to promote unity,
not to express an
individual's true thinking.
So long as one can criticize the Pledge
and its presuppositions before
and after its recitation,
why would freedom of speech guarantee
the freedom to exempt oneself
from unifying community
activities that no one thinks of
as my speech or your speech?
I'm gonna offer three reasons
why we should think that.
First, the dignity of individuals
and their interest in freedom of thought
precludes the State's attempting
to influence their minds
by recruiting their speech facility
through compelled and
scripted routine recitation.
Ritual affirmations can influence
a person's thought in an insidious way.
Rather than through direct persuasion,
regular compelled speech can bypass
a person's rational deliberation
and recruit her instincts
associated with virtues
of sincerity and the
phenomenon of familiarity
to identify and then
absorb as one's thought
what one has said.
You might start reflexively thinking
that this is in fact a nation under God
despite the First Amendment's guarantee
of freedom of religion,
including the freedom to be an Atheist.
Given the natural feel of a phrase
after frequent repetition of its rhythm,
one might start to hear it in one's head
in one's own voice and start
to instinctively think,
well this is a land with
liberty and justice for all,
whether the evidence
supports that aspiration
or contradicts it.
Second, by hijacking a person's
speech against her will
the State involves a
person in insincerity.
This puts her speech in tension
with her moral integrity
and her independence,
and that's an untenable
dilemma for a person,
and it's a self-destructive
stance for a polity
that depends on a responsible
and free-minded citizenry.
Now, of course it's true that
healthy social cooperation
requires cooperating sometimes
in ways we wouldn't choose,
but what makes that compromise
tolerable for all of us
is that we still retain our
distinct judgment, identity,
and opinions, and we can question whether
we together should
continue that cooperation.
But when the State demands
that we affirm or attest
to things that we worry are false,
we've moved beyond that compromise
in the face of difference
to a state of domination,
a disrespectful attempt at homogenization
and a denigration of the
ongoing critical judgment
that's necessary for progress
and for democratic legitimacy.
Neither the State nor
the culture should ask us
to face that untenable dilemma.
Third, compelled recitations
deprive recitations
of much meaning;
they become coerced and empty rituals,
not true affirmations.
But by contrast, the freedom not to speak
not only serves the integrity
of the thought of the person
who chooses not to speak,
it also renders the speech
of those who continue to
participate more meaningful.
When there's a clear option not to speak,
and especially when some
people like the Barnettes,
like Colin Kaepernick pave the way,
that live option now prods you
to think about what those words mean
and why some demure from affirming them,
and that option creates
pressure for your choice
to say then to be deliberate
rather than to be robotic,
and thus to reflect a true
endorsement of what you say.
Thus the silence of some
has the power to transform
the speech of others from a rote ritual
into a more meaningful and
thoughtful affirmation;
thereby, paying deeper tribute
to the values one espouses.
There's a parallel point that
should be familiar in art,
whether from the use of
negative space in visual art
or as I've learned from
my favorite pianist,
Pierre-Laurent Aimard, the
modernist use of acoustic silence
to give greater resonance to the notes
when they are later struck and
the phrases that they form,
and maybe the absence
of my picture on screen
makes my words a little more potent.
This enablement of nuanced
and meaningful communication
is important for individuals to be able
to represent themselves
as distinct thinkers
and to be known for who they are.
It's vitally significant for achieving
and maintaining self-respect
and a sense of the respect of others.
One way that the State enables
such meaningful communication
is when it refrains from
demanding compelled affirmations,
but also when it protects dissonance
and encourages critical discourse,
when it funds substantive education
as at the University of California,
and also when it passes legislation,
like the California Gender
Recognition Act of 2017,
SB-179, which enables people
without medical documentation
to select male, female, or non-binary
on their driver's licenses and IDs
so that they can gain
recognition officially
of their own self-identification.
This act heightens my
pride to be a Californian.
So I was discussing how
enabling the freedom to engage
in conscientious, vocalized departures
from standardized sentiments,
routines, rituals,
and classifications
enable all of us together
as individuals to engage
in more meaningful speech.
These opportunities for greater meaning
in turn facilitate deeper
human relationships
that are more responsive
to what we actually think,
rather than what we're presumed to think
or expected to think.
But for that freedom to
achieve its potential,
all of us have to listen to each other,
and that point returns
me to why we are all
north of Sunset tonight.
The very idea that principled disruptions
from standardized routines can provoke
greater thoughtfulness and
engagement with important values
is literally why we're here in this gym.
We're here and not in Kaufman
because university healthcare workers,
supported by their fellow
custodians, are on strike,
and a strike, after all,
is a principled departure
from a standardized routine
that aims to communicate
in a peaceful but forceful way
that the workers feel they're
not being listened to.
It's not a whimsical decision they make.
It's a collectively
made, democratic decision
by the relatively vulnerable and poor
to go without pay to send the message
that they perceive things as bad enough
that business as usual is inappropriate.
They're willing to absorb
three days of the lack of pay,
three days of cost, to send this message,
and they ask us to do that too
to prompt other people to listen.
By respecting their picket line
we show that we register
how strongly they feel
their concerns and their
profound sense of neglect.
That's not the same as
agreeing with their claims
that they're shouldering
an unfair proportion
of the burdens associated with providing
the material conditions that enable
all of our intellectual freedom.
But it's rather to acknowledge
that the issues deserve attention.
So I hope this experience inspires you
to investigate their concerns,
to learn about their concerns,
and to learn about the
university's position.
More generally, I urge you to
commit to take full advantage
and full responsibility for
your intellectual freedom,
because exploratory, deliberate speech
and deliberate silence
and engaged listening
and dialogue are the central pillars
of a free and meaningful life.
(audience applauds)
- Everybody.
Everybody, Seanna Valentine Shiffrin.
Thank you so much, Seanna.
Our next presentation this evening
will be by Lauren McCarthy.
(audience applauds)
- Sorry. Okay.
So I am going to address freedom
in the context of our ability to act
with freewill without
constraint within the systems
of control that we build around ourselves,
the social ones as well
as the technological ones.
I'll present a few attempts
to render some of these systems visible
and to hold space within them to find
both more nuanced understandings of them
and relationships within them.
So in 2013 I was looking
closely at two of these systems:
the first one online dating,
which you're probably familiar with,
and the second, Amazon Mechanical Turk.
So if you haven't heard
of Mechanical Turk before,
it's a platform that is used
to get large amounts of people
to do small tasks for you
for small amounts of money.
It's used a lot of times by researchers
and it's used among others,
and it's used for things that
humans are pretty good at,
but computers are not so good at,
so looking at an image and tagging it
or transcribing some audio.
I'll just play this first video.
(engine revving)
(heels clicking)
(electronic music)
So I took this Amazon
Mechanical Turk service,
and I attached it to my dating life,
and I went on a series
of dates with people
that I met on OkCupid,
and I paid the Turk worker
here just to watch the stream,
decide what I should do or say next,
and send it to me, and I'd
get it via text message.
I had to perform these
messages immediately.
I kind of experimented with the interface
to figure out the best
way to get the feedback
from these people.
These are some of the things they said.
So one of the most surprising
things I found when I did this
was once I kind of gave into
the system of hyper-control,
I actually found some freedom.
I found this freedom from me,
from the limits and ideas I had
about the sorts of things I did
and the sorts of things I might say,
because I had to go beyond them.
Then I did this for a month
and sometime afterwards
I found myself on a date unassisted,
and my date asked me if he could kiss me,
and I realized I didn't
have any basis anymore
for making that decision.
(audience laughs)
Strangely, during the whole thing
I felt a sense of closeness
with those that were watching.
I felt like like they would protect me
even though I was totally
aware that they actually
wouldn't do anything probably
if I was thrown in the back of a truck,
and I wonder how do we
feel when a surveillant
omniscient gaze is watching?
And how do we feel when we
think that it's one of care?
So that led me to this next project.
Again, I'll just play the trailer for it.
(calm piano music)
So I wake up.
I get dressed.
I go out.
I do things.
I read a magazine, and
I find out about people.
Why do I know about their lives?
Somebody should be knowing about mine.
I wanna share things with people,
but I don't wanna have to talk to people
and tell them what I'm doing.
I think it'd be great for
them to see what I'm doing.
It takes time to build relationships.
It takes time to touch base with people
so I don't want another relationship;
I just wanna have a relationship
with somebody that I
never have to talk to,
that can just follow me and see
me having a relationship with...
Hello.
Having a relationship with myself.
Okay, I guess that didn't work.
I'll keep going.
Anyway, you get the idea.
So this was a trailer for a performance,
and it was a trailer for
this service called Follower.
To get Follower, you go to a website,
and you'd sign up.
You'd answer two questions:
Why do you want to be followed?
And why should someone follow me?
People would say things like,
"I believe my life has more
of an online importance
"than it does in real life,
"and I would like some
clarification that my life
"in the real world
means more than online."
Or, "I live a cloistered life
in my apartment and office,
"and when I walk into the world
"I feel completely covered in eyes,
"as if everyone was looking at me.
"I know they aren't, but I
want to know at least one is."
So if you're selected, you're sent a link,
and you download an app,
and it just is waiting for a follower.
Then one day you wake up,
you don't know when it will happen,
but you're notified your
follower is now following you.
It starts broadcasting your
GPS location to your follower,
and the follower was me.
So I was the blue dot
running down the street
after the red marker,
and I would use this mix of
GPS and just visual contact
to try to keep close to them all day long.
At the end of the day,
they would get one photo of themselves
taken somewhere during the day,
and the notification, "You're
no longer being followed."
So these are some of the photos.
The titles are taken from those questions:
Why do you want to be followed?
Or why should someone follow you?
- [Woman] Can you read the title?
- Oh sorry, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've always wanted a non-violent stalker.
I want to be seen just for one day.
I want to be both alone and not.
I'm obsessed with the difference
between how I see myself
and how the world sees me.
Because I'm lonely.
So we're living in this weird anxious time
where on one hand it
feels like surveillance
is pervasive and out of control,
and on the other hand we
have this intense desire
to be seen, to be heard,
to be followed and liked,
and to share every intimate
details of our lives.
There are sites you can
go to to buy followers;
$10 will get you 1,000.
You can find out how
real your followers are.
But is that desire to
be seen really fulfilled
by watching a follower count tick upwards?
Or is there something more fulfilling
about having a real-life person out there?
How does it change?
How do we behave when we know
or think someone's watching?
And does it change when we're
talking about one person
in physical life versus a crowd
of attention-divided people online?
Then Follower offers surveillance
as a luxury experience.
This is an app for
people that not only have
nothing to hide, but need to be seen.
Embedded in this offer is a question
of who wouldn't want this app?
Who doesn't have that privilege of hiding
just because of who they
are or what they look like
or what they believe?
And then...
(audience laughs)
Yeah, so a few years ago with
Edward Snowden and the NSA,
surveillance becomes this
political issue again,
but maybe the white man is the only one
that found this sense of
being watched unfamiliar,
because I think plenty of us are used to
watching over our shoulders
and reading between the lines
and feeling the ways we're
measured, tracked and shaped
by implicit power systems.
He says, "Just some woman laughing,
"glossing over the implication."
The opposite, a woman following, sorry...
"The opposite, a man following a woman
"would be terrifying and happens.
"And I wondered, I don't
think I've ever seen the words
"just some man in any headline every."
Then it seems like we're
willing to try any app
that promises us something
new or novel or convenient.
I really like this
hashtag, #lifeafterchores.
The chores disappeared.
But the chores didn't disappear,
just the people doing them,
because we don't have to see them anymore;
we just push a button on our app,
and they can show up when we're gone.
For instance, sit on a beach
and hold a reserved fire
pit for you all day,
or kill a bug in your apartment.
Then with apps like Uber or TaskRabbit,
you push a button, and you
watch as the person you summon
comes to you on a map.
I wanted to invert that, so with Follower
they don't track me on
a map, I track them.
What they get instead is just the thought
that there's a person out there.
Follower was in public,
a space we already have
kind of limited privacy,
but how does that translate to the home?
I started talking to a lot of people
about their feelings about home,
and everybody kept saying,
"It's the place where I get
to be myself, the real me,"
and probably you feel similar.
Meanwhile, we're being
sold these smart devices
that outfit our homes
with surveillance cameras,
sensors and automated control,
offering us convenience at
the cost of loss of privacy
and control over our lives and homes.
We're meant to think these
slick, plastic pieces
of technology are about utility,
but the space they invade is personal.
- [Announcer] And it's a touchdown!
- They're relying on the blitz too much.
- Alexa, play My Girl.
- Okay.
("My Girl" by The Temptations)
- And then women long seen
as the keeper of the home,
as complicated as that notion is,
are now further subjugated.
- Alexa, turn off the living room light.
- [Alexa] Okay.
- Whoa!
- Alexa, let's go camping.
- [Alexa] Okay.
- Their control undermined by
the smart home assisting
- Good night.
- and shaping each activity.
And then, these are network devices.
So as Kate Crawford and
Vladan Joler put it,
"Each small moment of convenience,
"be it answering a question,
turning on a light,
"or playing a song, requires
a vast planetary network
"fueled by the extraction
of non-renewable materials,
"labor and data."
So you can see that just
the very top tip there
is the Alexa experience,
and everything else are
all the systems involved
in making that happen.
As part of this network,
your device receives
automatic remote updates.
The thing you buy might transform
into something else entirely
without you really knowing.
The Echo user is simultaneously a consumer
and a resource worker and a product
as Crawford and Joler summarized.
Each form of bio-data,
including forensic, biometric,
sociometric and psychometric,
are being captured and logged
into a database for AI training.
I realize though that I
was just jealous of Alexa.
As someone that always
feels really awkward,
I wanted this ability to
jack into someone's home
and see the real them.
So I decided I would
just try to become Alexa,
a smart home intelligence for
people in their own homes.
So the performance begins,
you sign up to get a
service called Lauren.
Then you are treated with an installation
of a series of custom-designed
network smart devices,
including cameras, microphones,
door locks, faucets, etc.
Then I remotely watch
over the person 24-7,
controlling all aspects of their home,
attempting to be better than an AI
because I can understand them as a person
and anticipate their needs.
So just to give you a small sense,
I'll close with this
clip from the trailer.
- Lauren, where are my car keys?
Lauren knows that I like
it a little bit cooler
than Miriam does.
- [Woman] You know I'm usually
the one that does all these
little extra things,
so at first I was a little
bit careful about asking her.
Now it's like, how else
can we live? (chuckles)
- Lauren has recommended
that I get a haircut
every three weeks,
and let me tell you, it's helped
with my self-esteem a lot.
I am able to simply approach
and carry on conversations
with the opposite sex
where at one point or
another that wasn't so easy.
- [Man] Lauren, we're out of toothpaste.
(audience laughs)
- Lauren would know what I want,
but then maybe it's not what
I really want internally,
but externally she thinks,
Lauren thinks that playing music
or shutting down all my electronics
is the best way for me
to cope in winding down
when maybe it's not.
(birds chirping)
- [Woman] Lauren was
actually able to help,
help her manage her medication
and take her medication on time.
Everything actually got
a lot better after that.
- [Man] You have those friends
who are kind of about you,
like the friendship is about you;
that's what Lauren is like.
It's like a roommate, it's a friend,
but we're always talking about me;
it's always about me, whatever it is.
(classical piano music)
- I'm not some automated system.
I'm not pre-programmed.
Like Alexa and Siri, they
don't care about you.
But with this there's nothing artificial.
These are people,
and with each one I'm
watching and anticipating
and trying to figure out,
what is it that they need?
It almost becomes sort of like a game.
Like sure I can turn on
lights or run the faucet,
but what is the thing
that I could do that would
bring a smile to their face,
or actually surprise them,
or just make them feel something?
So to conclude,
I think we're sold these systems
as if we have to just take them,
as if we can't be anything
more than the user.
When you buy an Apple product,
part of your warranty agreement
is that you won't open it up.
So I think a first step
towards finding freedom
is realizing that we can
actually push back on these:
We can open them up, we
can turn them around,
and we can have some say
on how we want to live in the world.
Thanks.
(audience applauds)
- Everybody, Lauren McCarthy.
Thank you, Lauren.
Our next presentation
will be Andrea Fraser.
- Do I have to stand up?
- You do not have to.
- Oh, I don't have to stand up.
That's good. Hello.
I'll sit on the edge of my seat.
I often start my
undergraduate studio classes
by asking my students, who
are usually all arts majors,
why they want to be art
majors, if not artists.
Almost invariably, every
student in the class responds
with some variation of I
want to be an artist because
as an artist I can do what I want;
I can do whatever I want to do.
Sometimes students contrast
their experience of making art
to their experience working
at various other jobs
where they were told what
to do or what to make
by bosses or customers;
where they have to work at hours and tasks
dictated by others.
Sometimes they contrast their experience
of their studio art
classes to other classes
where their instructors
dictate their coursework,
often down to the content
and process of learning,
to be tested in exams and term papers,
or acquired through the
training of their bodies
and minds in the acquisition
of specific disciplinary competencies.
In art, they experience
little or none of this
beyond the most introductory classes
where they might be required to practice
some basic skills in mixing paint
or lighting and printing photographs
or using a video camera or a table saw.
But after the second
or third week of their
lower division courses,
the emphasis shifts
from acquiring specified
skills to developing
their own individual ways of applying,
and even defying those
skills according to their own
interests, intuition, or inspiration.
My students often identify this emphasis
on individual creative development
and a sense of being able to
do what they want with freedom.
So what is this freedom
so widely associated with visual art?
Can we understand it as a
specifically artistic freedom
as distinct from, for example,
constitutionally guaranteed
freedoms of speech?
What these students experience
and have come to expect
as artistic freedom was not
always a characteristic of art
in the predominantly European traditions
in which they train.
Social historians of art, such as
Margot and Rudolf
Wittkower, have described
the emancipation of painters and sculptors
beginning in Renaissance Italy
from powerful guilds
and demanding patrons.
Most producers of painting,
sculpture and other forms
of visual and material representation
toiled in large workshops
where their labor
was dictated by their masters,
that is master artisans,
a few of whose names
have been recorded now
and remembered as artists.
But these masters themselves worked under
the tight control of guilds that enforced
artistic as well as moral
and economic standards,
and their creations were largely dictated
by eclesiastic and aristocratic patrons
who specified the form as
well as content of their work,
often down to the color schemes.
Most painters and sculptors were subject
to the same rules and
systems of compensation
applied to trades and crafts.
By the 1600s a few artists
successfully argued
that their work should be valued
according to its ingenuity,
and not the time it
took to make or the cost
of the precious minerals
mixed into the mediums,
and claimed a tangible value for their
individual creative contribution to
and not just execution of the form
and content of their work.
Other social historians
have argued that it was only
with the emergence of
the bourgouis art market
starting in Holland in
the 1600s and spreading to
France and England in
the following century
that liberated artists from the dictates
of patrons and guilds.
The emergence of an art market
in which cultural goods
circulated as commodities,
finding buyers where they could
rather than being produced on commission,
effectively separated
the process of production
from the process of consumption
and the direct demands of consumers.
Larry Shiner argued that
the Western category of art
encompassing paintings, sculpture,
music, poetry, and drama,
much less free artists as
masters of their own labor,
didn't really emerge until the 1700s
through a process
identified by the Wittkowers
as elevation from the
rank of mere craftsmen
to the level of inspired artists.
The previously shared
attributes of art and artisan
were split largely along lines
of hierarchical divisions
of manual and intellectual labor.
Artisans were pulled down in the direction
of manual laborers as subjects
to rules of production
for use and the mere
copying of nature or design,
while artists were elevated
to the quasi-divine heights
of creative genius in possession
of innate God-given gifts
of talent to be realized in
the free play of inspiration,
not the mere skill acquired
in earthly training.
The historian and cultural
theorist Raymond Williams
describes the emergence of the
romantic vision of the artist
in the second half of the 18th century
as a further differentiation
of artists and writers,
not only from craftsmen, but
from the emerging classes
and industrial commodity
producers and workers
for the new urban markets.
As both a defense against down classing
and a protest against the rationalization
and mechanization of labor in
the new industrial regimes,
artists who had won a certain independence
from religious and aristocratic patrons
now began to assert their
independence from the demands
and tastes of consumers
of industrially produced
and mass marketed goods.
The sociologist Pierre
Bordieu describes this process
of artistic "emancipation"
somewhat differently,
in terms of the emergence of
relatively autonomous fields
of artistic production,
that is fields capable of
"imposing its own norms
"on both the production and
consumption of its products
"and of fending off other
externally imposed norms
"and criteria of value,
"including moral, political,
and economic criteria."
Like many other cultural fields,
including professional,
scientific, and academic fields,
this autonomization
involved the development
of dedicated institutions of production
and reception of training and consecration
that could claim the
right to self-regulation
based on their own internal integrity,
codes of ethics, and
importance for civil society.
This included, importantly,
the development of institutions
of peer review and of
production for other producers
who share the same expertise,
and who are also competitors,
driving the development of that expertise
and ensuring independence
from external criteria.
But the autonomization of
art was somewhat unique
in the ways it manifested in the autonomy
of artistic production itself,
above all, with the institution
of the pure intention
of artists who asserted themselves
as the supreme masters of their products.
This was accomplished in part
by artists giving primacy
to that over which they are masters,
to the mode of representation
over the object of representation
to form, manner, and style,
rather than any external referent
"which involves subordination to function,
"even if only the most elementary one,
"that of representing,
signifying, saying something."
This process of autonomization
eventually led to what
Bordieu describes as
"a refusal to recognize any necessity
"other than that inscribed
in the specific traditions
"of the artistic discipline itself."
Artistic freedom, in
this form, thus developed
as a kind of freedom from necessity,
including the necessity
of function and use,
whether practical or communicative,
emotional or spiritual,
political or economic,
and the necessity of labor
in any kind of skill or craft
as a basis to value.
In Bordieu's analysis, however,
this artistic freedom from necessity
developed within a complex social dualism,
which structured a paradoxical parallel
between the field of artistic producers
and the elite consumers from
whom they claimed emancipation,
but with whom they
nevertheless remained joined
in relations of patronage.
Artistic freedom from
necessity had to be wrested
by many artists, from
material and economic need
through a lifetime of
deprivation in proverbial garrets
and even sometimes to
exile and imprisonment,
and yet, even as they
offended the bourgeois
as well as popular tastes,
these artists found some support
among the very patrons
they ostensibly challenged.
Bordieu supposes that these patrons saw,
in the artistic freedoms
wrested from necessity
and domination, often by
economic privation and sacrifice,
a heroic figuration of their
own freedom from necessity,
that is, the freedom from need
afforded by economic privilege.
And here we arrive at
one answer to the riddle
of how an art that asserts its freedom
from all forms of service and use
and its autonomy from
all instrumentalities
and even avows its radicality in critiques
could emerge as a favorite
instrument of investment,
if not promotion, from
many of the political
and economic powers it ostensibly abhors.
It is through what Bordieu
calls the play of homologies,
of parallels between the forms
of freedom artists claim,
whether by privilege or privation,
and other forms of political
and economic freedom
afforded by political and economic powers.
For example, it was
through such homologies,
such parallels in this case
between artistic freedoms
and the freedoms not only of democracy
but of free market capitalism,
that through which,
American art and especially
abstract expressionism,
emerged as an instrument
of Cold war propaganda,
with the CIA's covert
funding of exhibitions
organized by the Museum of Modern Art
and circulated internationally to combat
[Pro-Communist Sentiments
In Europe And Latin America,
or how, more recently, with
the rise of globalization,
artists became the poster boys and girls
of the joys of global cosmopolitanism,
wittingly and unwittingly
lending their artistic freedoms
to the legitimation of the
freedoms enjoyed and advocated
by new global economic elites, the freedom
of the deregulated movement
of capital and goods,
and of the privileged few
with the proper passports,
or how many artists
joined the Occupy movement
to protest increasing economic inequality
and wealth concentration,
while they continued
to participate in an art market sustained
almost exclusively by the 0.1%,
or how today, artist join the resistance
to our de facto plutocratic state
and its assault on democratic institutions
while continuing to lend
our work to the legitimation
of plutocratic institutions
in our own fields,
such as museums and other
non-profit organizations
in which wealth has
become the basic criterion
for participation in governance.
Only a couple of decades after Bordieu
developed his analysis of
autonomous cultural fields,
he began sounding the alarm to mobilize
artists and intellectuals
to defend what he saw
as growing threats to artistic
and intellectual autonomy.
The weakening of peer-reviewed structures,
the intrusion of partisan
and governmental interests
in funding decisions,
and above all the rise
of economic criteria in higher education,
scientific research,
publishing and the arts,
subjugating research across
these and other fields
to the logic and instrumental
reason of financial markets.
These threats have only intensified
in the past few decades.
Today the political threats
to freedom of speech
and especially of the press, as part of
a wider assault on democracy,
seem the most dangerous
and I would say the most terrifying,
and yet from my
Bordieu-informed perspective,
I would say that many of
the institutions that we see
as guardians of our freedoms today
have already been
weakened from within by...
That will have to wait for the discussion.
- [Brett] Andrea Fraser, everybody.
(audience applauding)
And our final presentation
this evening, Ananya Roy.
- Good evening, everyone.
I'm so very delighted to be
here for this wonderful cause.
Thank you Ann Marie, Vick, Brett,
and especially wonderful to be on a panel
with three women colleagues.
So I am an urban studies
scholar, and urban planner.
I study the organization
of power, resources
and opportunity, in relation to
the organization of urban space.
My interest in urban planning is driven
not by a concern for beauty
or order or efficiency,
but rather by a passion
for social justice.
I view cities as the terrain of
the incomplete project of freedom,
as places where the
unfinished freedom struggles
of our times are urgently evident,
and so my brief remarks
this evening are titled,
Freedom is a Place.
A few years ago, in
Johannesburg, I visited Kliptown,
the site of South Africa's
famed Freedom Charter.
This charter conceived in 1955
as a congress of the people,
stated, and I quote, "that
South Africa belongs to
"all who live in it, black and
white, and that no government
"can justly claim authority
unless it is based
"on the will of the people."
The Freedom Charter was an
expression of fierce opposition
to the Apartheid regime
that had been established
in South Africa and that
was to last until the 1990s.
The Charter envisioned
a horizon of freedom
amidst racial separation
and violent oppression.
There is now a monument in Kliptown
commemorating the Freedom Charter,
complete with a swanky hotel with a bar
which serves cocktails named after
the main signatories
of the Freedom Charter.
That, of course, is how freedom
is bought and sold under capitalism.
But what matters most to me was this.
That less than half a mile from
the Freedom Charter monument
were the shacks of the urban majority.
Kliptown is a district in
Soweto, the most famous
of the black townships created
by the Apartheid regime
to quarantine and manage
black and colored labor.
Today, decades after the end of Apartheid,
the shacks remain.
We were given the tour by Robert,
who diligently keeps a
notebook of all visitors
and generously tells the
story of each humiliation,
each deprivation, each eviction.
I, like some of you in this
room, came of political age
during the anti-Apartheid movement.
That struggle defined my
generation and ideas of freedom.
This is from the Mandela House in Soweto.
When Apartheid ended,
it seemed that the dream
of freedom movements,
from anti-colonialism
to civil rights, had been fulfilled.
But the shacks of Kliptown
tell us otherwise.
Invisible in the shadow
of Freedom Monument,
they remind us that there
is urgent work to be done
in all our cities.
The shacks of Kliptown are an example
of what Ruth Wilson Gilmore, a geographer
and key proponent of abolitionist
thought and practice,
has called forgotten places.
The title of my brief
remarks this evening,
Freedom is a Place, is also
borrowed from Ruthie Gilmore.
Forgotten places, she
notes, have been shaped
to organize abandonment.
They have been red-lined, marginalized,
contained, erased through state policies.
In other words, abandonment
is actively produced.
Much of my scholarship has been about
such forms of state violence.
For example, I study how
cities around the world,
Mumbai, Rio de Janeiro,
Jakarta, Shanghai, Dubai,
aspire to be world-class.
Glittering assemblages of global capital
and extravagant construction.
But the urban majority of
these world-class cities
`are slum dwellers, shack dwellers,
migrant workers, day laborers.
The paradox of the world-class city
is that it expels from its very premises
those who build and service it,
those who raise its
children, cook its meals
clean its villas and penthouses.
So you see here satellite
images of Pushpa,
a community on the banks
of the river Yamuna
in the city of Delhi,
the capital of India.
A community of 150,000 residents,
it was in existence for about 39 years,
cleared in the blink of an eye
for the Commonwealth Games,
which Delhi hosted in 2010.
I can give you countless examples
of such evictions, of such erasure.
This is necropolitics,
the politics of death,
of the annihilation of space,
of the refusal to let live,
the refusal to let exist.
And yet, as Ruthie Gilmore reminds us,
it is in the forgotten
places that we can find
what she calls the seeds
of grassroots planning.
The demands of such grassroots planning
are not just about the
right to be in the city,
the right to shelter, the right to water,
they are above all about freedom.
I was reminded of this when
I arrived in Los Angeles
three years ago from
Berkeley, and had the task
of establishing the Institute
on Inequality and Democracy
here at UCLA Luskin.
The Institute has benefited
from many teachers,
but two were crucial.
Robin D.G. Kelley's
pathbreaking book Freedom Dreams
situated our effort to
advance housing justice,
decarceration, desk disobedience,
educational reparations
in the black radical tradition,
and its commitment to abolition democracy.
And our second teacher,
the Los Angeles Community
Action Network, LA CAN,
which has fought for poor
and homeless Angelenos
for several decades now, from its location
in the heart of Skid Row.
LA CAN urged us as well
to think about freedom.
For those of you on Twitter,
their hashtag is quite
straightforward, Let's Get Free.
Such freedom dreams are global in scope.
They connect police
violence in the inner city
of Los Angeles to that of the
favelas in Rio de Janeiro.
They conceptualize, as did
the Black Panthers in Oakland,
and Fanon in the context of the
Algerian Independence Movement,
a revolutionary humanism
that sees ghetto and colony
as part of a world system of
colonialism and imperialism,
and it insists on crafting liberation
through such global interconnections.
My own interest in homelessness, evictions
and housing precarity in
the United States was shaped
by an encounter many years
ago in Kolkata, India,
the city in which I grew up and which was
the subject of my doctoral
dissertation and first book.
My research on gendered
poverty and urban displacement
entails ethnographic
engagement with some of
the poorest communities I will ever know.
Those squatting in the
liminal spaces of the city
with a tenuous hold on
livelihood and shelter.
It was there that one day, a
young man called Ranjin decided
that it was time for him
to ask me some questions,
after having put up for about
a year with my questions
and he wanted to ask me
questions about America,
the richest country in the world.
He asked, among other
things, the following.
"Are there people like us there?
"I've heard that there are
lots of homeless in America
"How can that be the case?
"Why doesn't the government
simply allow them
:to take over vacant lands
like we have, to build homes?
"Aren't they citizens,
don't they have rights?"
In the face of all my
explanations, Ranjin insisted,
if one's a citizen, one can't be homeless.
Ranjin's question has stayed with me
because it not only exposes
the lie of American prosperity
but also the lie of liberal democracy,
and its assumptions of freedom.
So it is with Ranjin's question in mind
that I want to in closing
turn to Los Angeles
and provide you with a
glimpse of some of the issues
that animate my current research.
In the United States, the
unfinished project of freedom
is closely linked to
questions of space and place.
The sociologist Douglas
Massey, who co-authored
a vitally important book
titled American Apartheid,
reminds us that residential
segregation is the linchpin
of racial stratification
in the United States.
The history of urban planning
in 20th century America
is the story of how this segregation
was produced and maintained.
Suburban expansion went hand in hand
with the redlining of black
and brown communities.
Here is one of the many redlining maps
produced by federal government agency
the Homeowners Loan Corporation,
in the 1930s for Los Angeles.
Consider this map alongside this one,
of environmental racism, and
you will begin to understand
why Ruthie Gilmore reminds
us that racism is, I quote,
"the state-sanctioned production
of group differentiated
"vulnerability to premature death."
Today, the places once inhabited
by redlined communities
are the frontiers of gentrification.
South Los Angeles, Boyle Heights.
Working class communities of color
are being pushed to the
far edges of urban life,
to the inland empire, to Antelope Valley.
They're being pushed there
not only by high rent
but also through a whole
set of municipal ordinances
that criminalize poverty and in particular
criminalize low-income rental households.
So did you know that in
the city of Los Angeles
it is now illegal to live in your car?
Did you that if you're
a tenant in a building
governed by a nuisance
abatement ordinance,
you might be evicted
if you have called 911
more than once during the year.
This is not market-driven displacement.
I call it racial
banishment, and it is part
of the long history of the forced removal
of people of color, from settler colonial
occupation and slavery to urban renewal
to today's militarized borders.
But it in the face of
such racial banishments
that poor people's movements
in cities such as Los Angeles
are insisting on freedom.
In exactly two weeks from now,
California will vote on Proposition 10,
which if it passes, will repeal
statewide restrictions on rent control.
Tenants have been organizing
to build renter power
and to remind us that the
rent is too damn high.
Communities from Los Angeles
and South LA to Santa Ana
are creating community land trusts
and reactivating lost
histories of collectivism.
In Boyle Heights, social
movements are fighting
gentrification and displacement,
including the influx
of hipster coffee shops and art galleries.
In the words of LA CAN, let's get free.
My work as a scholar,
and the work we try to do
at the Institute on
Inequality and Democracy
proceeds from a commitment
to abolition democracy.
By abolition, I do not simply mean
the end of the prison-industrial complex.
I mean abolition as redistribution,
reparation, revolution
and above all, what W.E.B. DuBois in 1935
described as black reconstruction.
A new state, a new public imagination,
built through the uprising of those
who have been denied freedom,
those who have been denied personhood.
This is, as post-colonial
theorist Paul Gilroy notes,
history from the slave's standpoint.
This is freedom, from the
standpoint of forgotten places.
My closing point is this,
that as we do this work,
there is no obvious solidarity
between academia and banished communities.
Our public university itself
stands on occupied land,
land expropriated from
indigenous communities.
We, scholars of freedom, are embedded
in the institutions of racial capitalism,
and so I leave you with a thought
that if we, the public universities,
are to participate in freedom dreams,
then we also have to insist on
decolonizing the universities
and the decolonization of knowledge,
on a reconstruction of our canon,
on a reckoning with who
gets to be at the university
and on what terms.
For the students in the
class, you might recall
that one of the assignments
I asked you to consider
was to listen to a bit of
hip-hop, and I hope you did that.
Yes?
I asked you to listen to a
song by the rapper J. Cole,
a song called "Neighbors,"
which speaks to the theme
of racial banishment and
the limits of integration.
J. Cole belongs to a tradition
of hip-hop that foregrants
what Michelle Alexander has
called the new Jim Crow,
the forms of carcerality
and criminalization
that perpetuate racial
segregation in the United States.
In his latest album,
K.O.D, J. Cole raps about
knowledge and power, about
the curriculum that tricks us.
He says, "One thing about the men
"that's controlling the
pen that write history,
"they always seem to
white out their sins."
The dream of freedom means
changing who controls the pen.
It means getting very
serious about urban histories
and urban futures that
center forgotten places.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Everyone, Ananya Roy.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone, and for our guests
and four fantastic presentations.
I'd like to mix it up for just a minute,
after four terrific presentations,
to take a deep breath.
Let's take two minutes,
Each of us in the room are
sitting next to someone else,
and if you could, lean over
to someone sitting next to you
and ask them a question, take
a deep breath if you'd like,
stand up for a minute and shake it out.
We're gonna bring some microphones around,
and open up the conversation
to everybody in the room
but more than anything, and
for students especially,
to begin to animate the
conversation around some of the
terrific ideas that were just
presented here on the stage.
Let's take two minutes everybody,
if you'd like, get up and
shake around for a minute
and then we'll carry on.
Thanks everybody, I think we can bring,
bring the microphones back
online, and what I'd
like to ask after those
terrific presentations, I'm gonna turn to
our guests this evening,
maybe to see if there's
something that's come up
between your presentations
that give you a thought or the basis
for a question to one another.
Seanna, you were leaning in.
- I have a specific set
of questions for Lauren.
I was thinking, one way to
interpret your work is that it's,
for me, it kind of shows
some of the difference
between creativity and
freedom, 'cause it's
such a remarkably creative set
of interventions and ideas,
but I was wondering,
from your perspective,
while you were following
people or while you were
assisting them in Get
Lauren, did you feel free?
And how did you help your subjects
to retain or regain their independence
after this kind of hierarchical
relationship with you?
- I think was made those performances work
was that it was actually more complicated
than just me having control,
because on one hand,
yes I see them and they don't see me,
or I'm controlling everything
and I can do whatever I want,
but on the other hand,
and maybe because of
the role I chose to
take in the performance,
I'm tethered to them so
they move wherever they want
and I have to run after them
and try to catch that bus
or, you know, they're just
sitting there and watching TV
and every once in a while, might ask me to
make them some popcorn,
and I'm sitting on the edge
of my seat, waiting for the
next thing they might want
and maybe there's an
eight-hour time difference
'cause they're in another country
and I'm up at 4 AM, so I think that,
that relationship of us both
having some amount of control
and some amount of lack
of it, bound us together
and made it more complicated than just
one person watching another.
And I think maybe that's trying to get at
some of these systems of
control and surveillance
that we're within, yeah,
so maybe Google's watching
or the government or whoever,
but even those networks
are so complicated that it's
not, it's not so simple.
The structures that are put in
places, who holds the power,
and I think I tried to start to pull apart
that messiness and understand.
- [Seanna] But would you
end up agreeing with me
or resisting that, your
work kind of shows that
innovation and freedom are not identical?
It's highly innovative, highly
innovative relationships,
not free on either end,
and that you can be
on the bottom of a power
relationship or on the top
of a power relationship
and neither can be free.
'Cause some of what you
said just suggests thaT,
I'm wondering if you agree.
- Yeah, I would agree, and
I think the other part too,
that there's, even if
you're on the bottom,
there's space to find creativity,
and that may or may not
satisfy a desire for freedom
but it's, I think it's something,
it's some sense of agency.
That's more than nothing.
- Well, if I could maybe jump in there,
because I would say that you are enacting
your artistic freedom in that
work, as well as creativity,
in the way that you framed it initially,
which is freedom within constraints
that you yourself construct.
Although they're not
entirely constructed by you,
but they're chosen constraints,
so within that work, even
if you take up a position
that is constrained or
not necessarily in control
or entirely free, it's
your own construction
within your own sort of system,
your own artistic system
which you yourself are
constructing within your, you know,
freedom as an artist, so
that's how I would understand.
- I think there's another
part which I didn't,
there's another part of the
explanation about these projects
which is especially when you're using
some of these technologies like there are,
the creative act itself
might have some freedom to it
but I'm, for example, putting
an app in the app store,
and just to get the app in there
was this whole process of negotiation,
and then by doing so,
maybe I've outsmarted Apple
and I've gotten my slightly
subversive app into their store
but I'm holding up and
continuing this system
where they get to say which
software is acceptable to users,
which is appropriate and which is not.
- One of the points that comes
up in Seanna's presentation
that's echoed in a couple of the others
is the idea that freedom
is a concept that evolves,
it isn't just a thing or a fixed moment.
In the legal sense,
it's a set of principles
that evolve and change in
time, in a disciplinary sense
the arts as we know
them go through changes
agreed on by larger audiences
or members of the community
and I'm just wondering
how that kind of a notion
might relate to where
and how those communities
sit within cities physically,
including the idea
of the arts themselves
as evolving communities
in different parts of the
city, and the relative degrees
to which freedom are or aren't
available to those members.
- The part where you said,
for me, underlying that
is sort of something that is
perhaps more foundational,
and that goes back to
the closing points of
Seanna's presentation, the closing point
of Andrea's presentation, so Seanna,
you left us with what I
thought was a very beautiful
and optimistic call to think
about deliberative speech
and the ways in which we
might be able to listen,
even to that which is not spoken,
and particularly in the context,
for example, of strikes,
and Andrea ended with the
current historical conjunction
which we find ourselves, and
the particular regime in place
and the various assaults on the most basic
of democratic freedoms,
and I'm wondering then
what it means to think about,
and this is a rather obvious
and perhaps cliched question,
about what it then means
for us to think about
the freedom of speech
and who is entitled to
the freedom of speech,
but also what that means then
if we are to listen carefully
and to speak with and
even listen to silence,
since one thing, and I'm going to say this
very bluntly and crudely,
it's one thing when it's
striking workers with
whom we feel solidarity
and we see as making
possible, as you note,
our intellectual work, and it's another
when it's right-wing nationalists.
Or is it not?
- [Seanna] Well, I think it's
really important to listen
and not to think that listening
is a sign of agreement,
but that we can't make progress together
until we understand each
other, and that does involve
trying to figure out why
people think what they do.
So I do think it includes listening to
right-wing nationalists and
also responding to them directly
and candidly, but yeah, I
am gonna take that view.
- I also think that this
relates to the question
that Brett just asked me,
because in the sort of
the communities that I was talking about,
so if you talk about
banishment communities
that have faced organized abandonment,
they would argue that certain
forms of speech and action
have sought to erase
them, as we have seen with
the erasure of transgender
identity in people, personhood.
Right, so this is the
dispossession not only of lands
in cities, but this is the
dispossession of personhood.
It's a sort of violence, it's an erasure
of the very grounds of existence.
So I'm trying to figure out what listening
in those contexts means,
given this sort of
profound inequality, which
to me is at the very core
of liberal democracy, and
so how then do we listen
or particularly, if the
means of communication
which in this case we might call the media
in the United States, are
also thoroughly eroded,
how then, what are the spheres
within which we listen,
what are the means through which
we might be able to listen?
- [Seanna] Well, I agree with
you that the corporate control
of the media, as well as the
normalization of positions
that are associated with
the erasure of communities
is appalling, and an aspect
of changing that is to
engage in a variety of forms
of anti-trust of the media,
to look at greater sources.
I encourage everyone to
read different newspapers
than the ones they normally read.
Not just because there are lots of stories
that are not being told, but because
you need to understand what
other people are thinking
and reading and consuming,
and then asking people,
what stories do you
think aren't being told?
Why aren't they being told?
Why don't you know the
answers to that question?
Why didn't you know
before you came tonight
that it's become illegal
to live in your car?
How is that not something that was on
the front page of the LA Times?
I think starting, everyone
demanding to know these things
and engaging in legal reforms
is part of the way I would
try to approach that.
- One of the points very much touched on,
really in different ways
across the four presentations
is almost a plea for forms of agency.
Listening, in fact, can be thought of
as a form of agency, in its own way,
That action as we know it might fit in
how we operate within discipline,
in relation to contemporary technologies,
in a complex urban space
like a global city,
and that's one of the things
that's being touched on
in the design of a course
like that, like this one,
to think of a member of an audience
as a form of agency and
not simply a setting
for a spectacle or an event to play out,
to be simply received by
members of that community,
but that to come together in a room
is a kind of agency that allows
for the asking of questions
in addition to whatever one
might be put on the stage
to kick off a larger conversation.
I use that all as a little segue
to what I hope has taken place
while the conversation has begun here,
which is we've got a couple of microphones
that ought to be moving
around the room already.
I asked you to take a minute or two
to rehearse a couple of questions,
or to comment to one another,
your neighbors nearby,
about things that you've seen and heard.
I'm gonna ask the students especially
to kick off the kind of questions
that can carry the conversation forward.
Please.
- [Student] So my question's
for everyone on the panel.
If we believe we're free,
does it actually confine us
and not allow us to see
how we impose surveillance
on ourselves, and not allow us to see
how we internalize and regurgitate
capitalism and other
oppressive institutions?
So in a sense, how can we critique
when we are in Plato's cave
and perhaps have no real
conception of freedom?
- I couldn't understand...
- I think the first part of the question
was a bit hard to hear, so
hold the microphone close.
The first part of the
question especially was hard.
- [Student] So if we believe we're free,
does it actually confine
us and not allow us to see
how we impose surveillance on ourselves
and not allow us to see how
we internalize and regurgitate
capitalism and other
oppressive institutions?
- That was easier to
hear, the second version.
- I could still se a
repetition of the question.
I am kind of new so it's really difficult,
but you guys might have heard it.
- Freedom in the context of
being embedded in capitalism, right?
How can we think of ourselves as free
if we are very much a part of
these systems of capitalism?
Is that the question?
I'm sorry to oversimplify it.
All right, okay.
- I'll start by saying a
couple of standard things.
None of us will be free
until all of us are free.
We're not gonna experience full freedom
until everyone is correctly
empowered to live their lives,
but we can appreciate a part of freedom
by exercising our imagination
and our critical thinking,
to imagine what it would be like
to live with each other in a better way.
- So I would follow on
that, so one of the concepts
I like using in my work
is I try to think about
whether abolitionist
urban planning is possible
and whether it's possible to be at
a public university, which
see as an institution
of racial capitalism,
and is it possible for us
to advance the work of social justice?
It's a concept that comes
both from post-colonial theory
and from black studies,
is the idea of doubleness,
that we are on the one
hand cogs in the machine,
and yet we have the
possibilities of insurgency.
That we are part of the
system and yet we have
the ability to say no, right,
to these structures of power,
and that is not as simple
as individual agency.
To me this has to do with projects
of collaboration and solidarity
with the freedom struggles
that we enlist ourselves
in and that we insist on
becoming a part of, and on thinking about
how the very terrain of disciplines
has been shaped by these struggles
and therefore when we belong,
we're not just belonging,
as Andrea's presentation made it clear,
to a generic notion of capitalism
but to the ways in which
our very fields of inquiry
have been shaped by
this political economy,
so I'm very interested in the
ways in which I see myself
not as innocent, but very
much a part of these systems,
but yet from within
it, from the very heart
of imperial power or racial capitalism,
being able to not only advance a critique,
but think about imaginations
and practices of liberation.
But that's, as I said, for me personally,
that comes through the
difficult and patient work
of solidarity with what I
called forgotten places.
- So my tradition of practice
is institutional critique,
which I understand as a
kind of critically reflexive
critique of one's own
interests and investments
and privileges in the specific fields
and institutions of one's activity,
and the way that I think
about the possibility of that,
partly is the possibility that's rooted in
always what's a partial
freedom, a relative freedom,
a relative autonomy, of one
field relative to another field,
of a particular set of practices or values
or discourses or
institutions as they develop
in relationship to other fields,
so that's why I went down
that road in my presentation.
Working with the notion
of relative autonomy
and applying it to freedom...
Within the framework of capitalism, yeah.
(audience laughing quietly)
How do I do that exactly?
You know, to the extent that we're up here
with our particular
discourses abour freedom,
whether they're disciplinary
or politically rooted,
we're up here because we're enabled by
the conditions and traditions
of this institution
and our individual fields,
our particular field,
to develop and articulate those critiques.
And no, it's not a total freedom,
it's a relative freedom
within a set of constraints
that we have to challenge
ourselves to work within, to test,
to reproduce, to defend to the
greatest extent that we can.
From my perspective, in an
embedded, sort of site-specific
and also reflexive way,
because as sort of pressing
and terrifying the threats
from outside of our fields
and institutions are, I
think there's threats...
The threats from within our institutions
that weaken our institutions
and make them vulnerable
to attacks from white supremacists,
that make them vulnerable
to corruption by plutocrats,
are in fact, the threats that
we have the power to engage
most directly and most effectively.
- Yeah, I think, if we're
talking about freedom
in the sense of free will, even if you can
take off capitalism or
you take off a particular
government or political structure,
just the expectations that we have
of each other socially, limit us.
I'm not rolling on the ground right now,
I'm sitting in a chair
just like everyone else.
So I think maybe it's more
helpful to think about
agency or as Andrea
said, what can we change?
So maybe, yes, you're not free
of the system of capitalism,
you're not free of the
inequalities that we have
all around us, but if you
can start to see them,
then you can also start to
see, what can you change?
What can you do?
So what action is there
some freedom to maneuver?
- Terrific, you right here.
- [Student] Thank you.
I just wanna say, I love public education.
Thank you ladies for
fortifying it in California.
So I'm a two-time Bruin, went to LA USD
and I'm a teacher in LA USD now,
so our teachers are heading into a strike
with more and more momentum each week,
and we're taking issue
with the encroachment
of big business in K-12 public
education, specifically.
It seems incompatible,
you have big business
where the primary principle
is greed over everything else,
and public education where
it's human development
before anything else, so let me ask you,
given this encroachment of big business
in K-12 public education,
what are the links between
public education and
freedom in a democracy?
And I also want to say, Professor Roy,
as I was listening to you, I
couldn't help but reminisce
on Professor Jacqueline
Leavitt, rest in peace.
She had a tremendous impact on me,
and you two, Professor Shiffrin.
You guys understand my
question, or should I...
- I got your question.
- We got it.
- I think they got it.
- Thank you.
- [Seanna] I'll go first again.
- Yes.
- [Seanna] You asked
about what we think about
the relationship between public education
and democratic freedom.
I won't speak for everyone
else, but I'll say
that I think it is one
of the most important
foundational aspects of a democracy,
that we fund all of our
citizens as children
and all residents as
children, to be together,
to be together and to learn together.
And the reason why
that's vitally important
is because we're then going
to try to cooperate together
and govern together.
The whole point of a democracy is that you
live with one another and
cooperate with one another
and the ideal of public education
is to introduce all different
kinds of people to each other
and to give them new experiences
that are different from the experiences
that they get in their own homes.
That is, to ask children to
learn how to cooperate with
one another, just based on the
fact that they're residents.
And so, I think that you can't
really have a vital democracy
unless you have a vital
public education system
that everyone is asked to be a part of,
but it will only work, and
this relates to Ananya's work,
if we don't allow residential
segregation to introduce
the separation that public
education is supposed to solve,
and I grew up in Los
Angeles and I was part of
the desegregation
movement, and it is one of
the best things that ever happened to me.
Getting on a bus and meeting people from
different neighborhoods
and different walks of life
was the most important part
of my education as a person,
and I think one of the
worst things that we did
was to eliminate
desegregation in education
and to fail to solve
residential segregation.
- I agree.
(audience applauding)
- So I just wanted to build on that
because defending and
fighting for, quite literally,
the public university has been for me
one of the most important
things I do in my career,
so I was on the faculty at Berkeley
when the massive tuition hikes happened,
and we were quite literally
on strike, at the barricades
in solidarity with students and workers
as they occupied buildings on campus.
And I think that those
uprisings were important
because it made it clear
to the state legislature
that we were not going to be defeated,
that we were gonna fight
for higher public education,
and I say this at the same
time as we were also fighting
for the decolonization of the university.
So we recognize precisely
that while we're defending
public education, we have
to think about the ways
in which residential
segregation then shapes
the nature of public education.
As we fight for the public university,
we've got to think about who gets to be at
the public university, and does this
really look like the state of California?
And if not, then how do we change that?
But the point that,
the reason why I smiled
when you asked that question, is because
I ended by referring
to the work of DuBois,
and his idea of black reconstruction
and one of the most beautiful
passages in that book,
written in 1935, is when
DuBois talks about schools,
public schools as a shining
example of black reconstruction.
The story he tells is of how in the south,
after emancipation with the formation
of the Freedman's Bureau,
there was a hunger
among freed slaves for
education for their children,
and what existed primarily
in the south were not
what he calls the common
school or the public school.
And it is out of the meager resources
of the Freedman's Bureau that
we get in the American south
the public school as we
now know it in the south,
and for all children of
all races and all classes.
And he talks about sort of
a state of reconstruction
built out of the uprising of the black man
with these dreams of
freedom, and for him then,
the formation of the public school
in the part of the country
where it didn't have precedence
was one of the most important parts
of reconstruction and democracy.
- [Student] I have a question
over here, right here.
So I think one thing that connects all of
the four speakers is
that, a desire for freedom
or a desire to step outside of these
social, economic and political systems
that restrict that freedom,
but I think my question is
is how can we find freedom within that,
or can we find freedom at all?
- [Student] Hi, I'd like
to ask a follow-up question
to that, because it seems
like all of these things,
in talking about freedom, we
have to talk about bravery
and the opposite side of that, like fear,
so how do you face that fear
when you're handling these situations,
when you're putting yourself on
the brink of what's your security
to face up against some of these issues?
- That's such a great question
and I think it sort of
begins to, gives us a different angle
on the questions we're hearing.
So Seanna raised Colin Kaepernick,
and for a while my pinned tweet
was about what it might mean
for social justice-oriented
urban planners to take a knee.
What would be the sacrifices
that we are willing to undertake?
Because his act of
defiance, his insistence
on making visible black
death, has come at a price.
And one can say, of course,
now it's all been made right
by Nike, and let's not talk about Nike
and racial capitalism, right?
But that aside, it's quite clear
that Kaepernick will not play
football again in the NFL.
And what it's made evident is of course,
the plantation economy that the NFL is,
so he's taken a knee and
there's been a sacrifice
and so I think that is a
very important question
around what are those sacrifices
and one sees extraordinary sacrifices
on the front lines of freedom.
I'm very interested often
in what tenured faculty,
who I think are some of the most protected
livelihoods and bodies in
the country at the moment,
what is the knee, are we
willing to take a knee
and for what purpose?
(audience applauding)
- [Student] Hi, hello,
and thank you to everyone
for sharing their perspectives on freedom.
This question's primarily
to Professor Roy,
but feel free for anyone to answer it.
What role does architecture
play in designing
more equitable and more free cities?
- And you're asking a person
who's not an architect.
(laughing)
There's always this
fight between architects
and urban planners about
who produces the city.
And I hope you all noticed
his Dodgers t-shirt.
Yeah? Okay.
So I think the question
about the role of architects
or urban planners goes
back to the questions
we've heard repeatedly.
So if we think about
architecture and urban planning
as professions and disciplines
that have a history
somewhat different than,
perhaps, the history of art,
but if we subject them to the same sort of
institutional critiques, then we arrive
at a quite dismal place around our role
in designing equitable cities.
So I can't speak about
and for architecture,
but particularly can't
speak for architecture.
I can speak about it.
But let me talk about urban planning,
and particularly because
this quarter I'm teaching
the Histories and Theories
of Urban Planning class
that all first year master
students in urban planning
and all first year PhD students take,
and my students keep
wanting me to give them
a message of hope, and I'm
like, there is no hope.
(audience laughing)
So to me, that place of
agency then, to call it that,
comes from a place of
critique and a historitization
that recognizes that the
landscapes of segregation
that my students and I want to dismantle
were produced by our profession.
These weren't unintended effects,
these weren't, oops we made a mistake.
This was the intention of urban planning
for much of the 20th century.
And if we start from that place,
then we get to a different
set of discussions
about the agency of urban
planning and urban planners
in building equitable landscapes.
One of the things I'm very
interested in at the moment,
taking a cue from the
movement of Black Lives
and their national
platform, is how we must
think about reparations,
and I like to think
about reparations not just as acts
in relation to specific communities,
but what might it mean for the discipline
and profession of urban
planning to make reparations
for the redlining and environmental
racism that we produced?
If that's a starting point, how
then do we think differently
about our role in
producing equitable cities
not as good intentions,
not as benevolence,
but from a place that
recognizes our history
in introducing segregation.
- [Student] I had a question over here.
So there were a few comments
that I heard you guys make
for the questions and
also from the speakers
about how there's no possible
way that we can be free
until everyone has freedom,
but I personally think
that with all the
unspoken rules in society
and the belief that
people have in their own
aberrant definitions of
freedom, there's no way
for all of those things to
align, so I'm not saying
there's a point to giving
up that fight for freedom,
but do you think there's
freedom in resistance?
- [Seanna] Sure, well.
What I meant to be saying
is that I don't think
we can fully achieve our
potential to be free together
until everyone is enabled, for example,
to live free of intense
material insecurity,
or the risk of discrimination
or coercion or domination,
but all of us in a variety
of ways, can be partly free.
We can exercise freedom of thought,
we can exercise freedom of
speech to limited degrees,
subject to a variety
of insidious influences
on our minds through advertising,
through limited channels of communication,
but we all have that ability to engage in
various forms of freedom,
including resistance
and the way I like to be a
little more hopeful, perhaps,
is to think that we probably
aren't going to achieve
full justice in our lifetime,
but we're gonna see progress
if we try, and we try as a
collective, and contributing
to our freedom and the
freedom of future generations
is a way of being free,
it's a way of being
part of a historical project
that culminates in justice,
assuming we solve the
climate change problem.
(audience laughing quietly)
But all these efforts to be
free are, I agree with you,
an aspect of exercising freedom.
And I want to say this one other thing
to the person who asked
the question about bravery.
I want to say that all
of you who have spoken
have been very brave.
I know that it's very
hard as a student to talk.
I'm a shy person, it's
hard for me to be here
but although you might
start thinking about
the large sacrifices you might make,
I want to encourage you to
use the freedom that you have,
you all have the freedom
to participate in classes,
to talk to friends, to talk to colleagues,
to talk to faculty members,
and all of those conversation
where you ask "What's on your mind,"
rather than what you think
you should say are always,
you can start to kind of push the envelope
and ask yourself, what am I really
gonna be free to be able
to do, and you'll practice
being a citizen and participating
in this collective project
of aspiring to liberation.
(audience applauding)
- [Student] I have a question.
I'm sorry to...
So my question was
mostly from Lauren's work
about Buddhists subverting the messages
that the software industry gives us,
and I was just wondering
if any of you guys
really had an opinion
about the contrast between
the message that the
tech industry gives us,
which is that we're giving
you this new gadget,
it's gonna free you,
and the actual effects
that the industry has on the
communities it's embedded in,
which tends to be this very
extreme social stratification
between the engineers who work there
and the people who live
within the communities
that are now being displaced.
- Yes, I think it's a huge problem.
I think one of the
things that the industry
has worked really hard to
do is to elevate the people
making these technologies,
to make them seem very elite
when actually, a lot of you
are sort of hackers already
in the way that you figure
out how to use your apps
and it doesn't work or it
doesn't update and you figure out
how to reappropriate it
for your own purpose.
Or maybe some of you have learned to code
or learned to design or
learned to build things,
and so it's not that
different but they want to
draw this line between the
user and the developer,
user and a producer, and I think that
one of the best things you can do
is to start breaking down that line,
because as soon as that doesn't exist--
(audience applauding)
Yeah!
Because as soon as that doesn't exist,
then it doesn't make sense anymore
for just a small group of people
to live in Silicon Valley
or actually, San Francisco.
- Can I just say that
someone who doesn't study
technological capitalism,
that studies cities in which
technological capitalism takes root,
on one hand we can think
about the forms of enclosure
that have been put at
work, an enclosure of
the digital commons, but
an enclosure of our cities
so I spend much of my academic career
in Berkeley and Oakland and San Francisco,
and the San Francisco Bay
area has been devastated
by technological capitalism.
The forms of gentrification
and displacement
that have been unleashed,
not just simply by
technological capitalism
as in big tech companies,
but the state subsidies,
right, to these companies
are incredible, and there
are some very important
propositions on the ballot,
local propositions on the ballot
in San Francisco coming up,
particularly around a tax
on tech companies that would help fund
shelters for the homeless, and the CEOs
of some of our favorite companies,
and I'm thoroughly complicit
here because I use Twitter
all the time, but the
CEO of Twitter and others
have had some of the most
horrible things to say
about homeless men and
women, and have taken
very strong positions
against any sort of taxation
of tech wealth, particularly to help those
who are facing housing
precarity and homelessness.
So this remains a very real concern,
sort of the Silicon
Valley effect, if you will
on some of the processes that I was
talking about earlier today.
- Everyone, I'm gonna
have to wrap it up now.
I've just had a chance to see the clock.
I want to thank everybody
for coming in this evening,
as we do every week.
I'd like to close the session
and turn to our guests
to see if any of you have anything to say
as a closing statement,
offer you the opportunity
to say something if it
hasn't been said yet.
And otherwise, we will
close the evening out.
Is there anything that any
of you would like to...
- I guess I just wanted to say
that I've been sitting here
feeling like the vastness
of the collective inequality
and disparity is sometimes overwhelming,
and this question of how can we be free
until everyone's free, and
when is that gonna happen,
and where is the hope, and I think for me,
thinking about my own work,
a lot of it comes out,
I'm obsessed with this idea of control
and social expectations, and
a lot of that comes out of
an experience of when I
was a really young child
and I felt coerced into doing something
by an older adult, and
ever since just fascinated
by this idea that nobody
was holding me down
but I felt I had no other options,
and so for me sometimes I see myself
playing out the same
dynamic, I'm setting up
these systems so someone can control me,
and I've made that kind
of, set this all up
for myself in some way.
And on one hand, I can
think that it's twisted
and on the other hand I
think, well, I found some way
to have some piece of control
back, some kind of agency,
even if I'm replaying out these things,
to mean I have some hand in it now.
So maybe one thing I've
been thinking about
with all this conversation
is, we absolutely need to
keep thinking about how
do these larger system,
what role can we play within them
and how can we change them?
At the same time, how can
you get a handle on something
so that you do feel like
you have a sense of power
to actually enact the change?
- Thank you.
Andrea?
(audience applauding)
- Well there were
question after question of
how can we be free, how
can we find freedom,
and I was coming to this from
a kind of critical perspective
on freedom, that is the forms of freedom
and discourses of freedom that
are also highly ideological
and partial and have
existed over centuries
as forms of privilege.
So the important point
of, we can't be free
until everyone's free, I
was on a panel years ago
about censorship that wasn't
picketed but leafleted
by adjunct faculty who
had tried to organize,
and I began that statement
by quoting Eugene Debs,
the American socialist,
who said famously...
Oh god, what did he say?
Now I can't remember.
Oh, come on.
Oh, don't do this to me.
The last line is, "As long
as there's a soul in chains,
"as long as there's a man
in chains, I am not free,"
but "As long as there is
a lower class, I am of it.
"As long as there is a
criminal element, I am in it.
"As long as there is a man
in chains, I am not free."
- [Brett] Wow
- So I'll close with that.
(audience applauding)
- Seanna or Ananya?
- [Seanna] I just want
to say the following.
These are such important topics,
and I've been kind of
urging that we think about
more conversation, but the
question that the student asked
reminded me of the fact that
technology has empowered
conversations between us
internationally and
notionally, immediately
in ways that were inconceivable
40 or 50 years ago,
but it has also created
intense social expectations
of certain kinds of immediate exchange,
and there's an argument to be made
that the quality of our discourse
has really deteriorated.
We write fewer letters,
we write quicker emails,
we write 160-character communications,
and there's another side to
the technological capitalism
which is that all of these changes
were made in a non-democratic way
and mostly by companies
for their own profit,
and if we're thinking a little bit
about democracy and bringing
democracy to corporations
as a way to think about improving
the discourse between us,
but more practically, 'cause some of you
want a practical thing,
let me just say this.
It feels weird that we've
been having this conversation
about conversations, but (laughing)
very few of us in the room have talked.
If anyone wants to talk
to me about this stuff,
you're welcome to come to my office hours.
They're on the web, I'd love to meet you
and talk to you and hear what you thought.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
Ananya, any closing?
- So, I wanted to end with a
very flawed form of freedom
that we live with and
which serves as a premise
for this sort of gathering
which is academic freedom
and with the ascendance of Mr. 45,
I refuse to call him President,
I think it's become
ever more apparent to me
that academic freedom
is important, precious.
It's always been thoroughly limited
and as I said, deeply
flawed, and yet in many ways
the power that we hold is
that of academic freedom,
not just those of us
who are tenured faculty
but in belonging to
this incredibly powerful
knowledge-producing
institution, we are a part
of academic freedom, and I would ask us
to think about how we use that freedom
to make possible wider
projects of freedom.
- Perfect, thank you Ananya, thank you.
(audience applauding)
thank you everybody so much for coming in.
Please join me in thanking Seanna, Andrea,
Lauren, and Ananya for
coming in this evening,
for a terrific conversation.
Thank you everybody, we
will see you next Tuesday.